[Music]
they thought it was funny to lean into
it and it was like I wonder if you could
put a dollar amount of value that that
like I have the craziest story for you
right now Paul Walker and his brother
Caleb Walker were at our Premiere so the
first time it showed and they saw that
and they said to each other that's the
restaurant we got a franchise
and they franchised it they Caleb Walker
now his brother his brother that so he
has two brothers Paul Walker and Caleb's
the one who looks like him and plays him
in the the last movie The Furious Fast
and furiously he was and they came and
they franchised because they saw in the
dark dude we advance rad like what do
you mean the franchise they bought a
couple stores
opened a location yeah they have one in
Huntington Beach the that's their Bella
Terrier it's yep it's the Walker
families wow yeah they're part of The
Chronic Taco like family they're one of
their franchisees yeah what Jackass 3D
did for the brand of Chronic Tacos has
to be like that yeah it has to be a lot
that's one big thing right there you
know right so they were he told me
because we were thinking of doing
another restaurant and then we go there
and we sit that and Paul looked at him
goes no we're doing this well how many
stores did you have at uh j3 at j3 I
think we had three or four right no we
the the Brand's been around for a little
bit I I joined it started in 2002 and by
the time I joined in 2008 it had 26. oh
wow and then how many do you have now we
have 50 now but we've gotten up to 60.
60 so there's ones that have closed ones
that have opened and like we've gone
through a lot of everything
oh we did definitely trim the fat during
the pandemic yeah but now ever since
we're on a roll like it we're we're even
in La so what are the chances
realistically of us getting Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole into Chronic
Tacos done yes
you're my bro dude I remember we were
talking about at some point like a Stevo
uh like veggie burrito kind of a
situation or something yeah I don't know
if that makes sense but dude no the
Stevo hot sauce
dead right here that would mean Sign
Sealed and Delivered
Friday Friday when we go to the when we
go to tight box yeah and we're doing all
that I'll make the call
I gotta stop by on the way down and
we'll ship them out that's cool yeah way
to go and uh don't you guys have
something else going on Friday too yeah
well the reason we're going down to
tight box packing is to sign our new
skateboard what do they look like
[Music]
heavy metal regalia spandex animal print
pants just animal print headband just
chopped up heavy metal shirt like oh
it's so dope but what people have to
know too these aren't heat transfer
Graphics these are screen printed old
school yeah old school style and look at
all the colors we did
in half ass we're doing these boards for
real that's cool and uh yeah I love it I
loved when you sent me so I had a photo
in Wild Boys where I looked exactly like
this because we did a heavy metal uh
blood bath or something it was the
rattlesnake techno no the snake bite
tattoo snake bite tattoo we were all
metaled out and I had a photo by myself
like this and Stevo sent it to me
because dude I've always loved as well
I'm like oh thanks
and then next thing you know he's like
dude let's do a metal board together
yeah and I'm like if that's what you
want to do bro I'm down I think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome as
awesome is hard kicking the nuts what
I've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first book's five-star
rated on Amazon and I have no doubt this
one will be too so get the autograph
copy right now at stevo.com
yeah dude